[Music]
have you ever met someone who didn't
love Harry Potter with every fiber of
their being if so you probably called
them a muggle and distance yourself from
them and if we don't blame you after all
no one needs that kind of negativity in
their life stay tuned to find out why
Dumbledore isn't as innocent as he seems
to be hey wizards don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things let's jump right into the
ten dark Harry Potter theories that were
actually confirmed by JK Rowling a
Wizards lifespan have you ever wondered
why Professor Dumbledore looks like he
was about to topple over at any given
moment we sure have and we weren't alone
in doing so author JK Rowling has often
hinted that there are many differences
between wizards and muggles well it
turns out that their lifespan is one of
them while the average human can live up
to 80 years old the harry potter creator
revealed that wizards could actually
live for about 200 years at the time of
his death Dumbledore was about 150 years
old
so in short he actually could have lived
another 50 years on another note it was
Lord Voldemort's greatest desire to
become immortal however he died about
130 years prematurely if he had simply
refrained from putting himself in
precarious situations he might have
lived for centuries instead he chose to
split his soul apart in case someone
managed to take him down at the time
securing his soul into objects might
have made total sense but his plans sure
did fail poor Baldy if he only had made
some better life choices
trouble in paradise for Ron and Hermione
many of us were rooting for Ron and
Hermione to lock lips during the final
Harry Potter movie however some people
weren't exactly keen about the newfound
relationship when you think about it Ron
and Hermione are the least compatible
people in the world hermione is highly
driven intelligent and uptight whereas
Ron is lazy a bit slow and as loose as a
goose
knowing this it's kind of hard to
believe that these two characters end up
together and JK Rowling agrees the
author has stated that her decision to
pair these two characters together had
everything to do with personal reasons
and not credibility sure they
have a world wind in common but
opposites attract
right JK Rowling also revealed that Ron
and Hermione nice relationship wouldn't
always be filled with gumdrops and lemon
squares
in fact she mentioned that they would
meet many issues down the road and even
resort to muggle couples counseling to
fix them if you thought that Ron and
Hermione were a match made in heaven
we're very sorry to have burst your
bubble hold tight though because more
uneasy theories are coming your way
emotional scars it goes without saying
that war is never pretty sure sometimes
the good side can prevail but there is
no going back to the way things used to
be for this reason and many others JK
Rowling had a great deal of difficulty
writing the Battle of Hogwarts since it
is common for authors to fall in love
with their characters one can only
imagine how hard it was for Rowling to
kill them off in fact the decision was
so intense that she still makes it a
point to mention these characters on
their death anniversary well enough
about the ones who were lost and let's
switch to our focus to those who were
left behind hundreds of students risk
their lives for the Wizarding World
during this epic battle according to
Rowling most of these students have
never been able to shake the fear and
sadness they felt that day these
feelings continue to follow these
characters to this very moment
in fact many of these characters named
their children after the ones who
tragically lost their lives during this
battle in the end some things are simply
too big to get over so long chunks and
Remus there is nothing easy about
reading Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hollows especially since so many amazing
characters get killed off on may 2nd of
every year Rowling makes it a point to
apologize for killing Tonks and Lupin
during the Battle of Hogwarts
however she made it clear that she
simply had to there were many reasons
behind her decision but perhaps the
biggest one is that harry's loved ones
had to die since people like Ron
Hermione and a golden few were out of
the question
Rowling set her sights on the lupins
according to the author she was
struggling to choose between killing off
Arthur Weasley or Remus Lupin and she
chose the latter
keeping the Weasleys as whole as
possible was an obvious choice
especially since Fred was fated to
perish during this wicked battle the
author also commented on how fitting the
couple's death
would be in the end it was sort of like
history was repeating itself in this
case Thomson Lupin resembled Lily and
James Potter respectively it was also
fitting that Harry would get to raise an
orphaned child however Harry would never
treat Teddy Lupin like the Dursleys
treated him with you the forever room
the fact that Harry had to grow up
without parents is absolutely
devastating however things could have
been worse Harry's mom and dad gave
their life to save their baby boy when
it comes to Neville Longbottom parents
though the same can be said
Neville also had to grow up without
parents but he did have the chance to
meet them just not in the heartwarming
way one might think Alice and Frank
Longbottom were good people who managed
to withstand being tortured by Bellatrix
Lestrange their will to keep their
secrets hidden cost them their sanity
though and it's something they were
never able to recover from many of us
were hopeful that never would one day be
able to talk to his mom and dad about
the brave acts he committed sadly never
we'll never be able to do so Rowling
confirmed that Frank and Alice would
always remain the same and that nothing
could ever change them since wizards and
witches can live for centuries they are
fated to remain at st. Mungo's hospital
of magical maladies until the day that
they pass over this is also applicable
to anyone who has suffered a memory
spell like our dear old professor
Lockhart in the end though we'd rather
he be locked up in the forever room
instead of Ron who he tried to obliviate
Dumbledore is gay Albus Dumbledore is
unlike any character in the Harry Potter
series his selfless nature and
charismatic ways have made it impossible
not to love him while he may be a
prominent figure in the Harry Potter
world there is little to be known about
his character sure he's the headmaster
at Hogwarts and he's one of the best
wizards in the world but what about his
social life from what we know he's never
been married before nor has he had any
children of his own the only thing we do
know about him is that he has a brother
and had a sister once upon a time this
information was only spilled during
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows but
before that the man was a total mystery
while rolling might have described him
as a man with a twinkle in his eyes we
never once put two and two
and realized that he was gay in the end
who a person chooses to love doesn't
change anything but to say that we
weren't shocked about this revelation
would be a lie when rollin confirms that
Dumbledore was in fact gay some of her
fans were outraged this only seemed to
amuse the hilarious author as a person
or character's sexual orientation
shouldn't make a difference in someone's
life I never liked these curtains set
them on fire in my fourth year by
accident of course Snape is gray Severus
Snape was a man of few words but when he
spoke you could be sure that nothing
good was about to be said he was crude
rude and severe despite being a teacher
he found little joy in helping his
students achieve greatness throughout
the entire Harry Potter series many of
us grew up to hate and mistrust Snape
his allegiance seemed to rely on what
was best for him in the moment
regardless of how things seemed to be it
was later revealed that Snape was in
fact a good guy and the best double
agent we'd ever seen after killing
Dumbledore Snape was seen as the big bad
guy but in the end he took no pleasure
in murdering his good friend when Harry
finds out the truth about snake he is
practically moved to tears so much so
that he gives his son his name it's easy
to forget that Snape was a bad guy
considering how much he gave up to save
the Wizarding World
but as Rowling has put it Snape is gray
by this she means that he is not black
or white but smacked down in the middle
his love for Lily Potter caused him to
reconsider his lifestyle but if it
hadn't been for that he might really
have enjoyed being a Death Eater yes
[Music]
the truth about purebloods one of the
most prestigious titles in the Wizarding
World is the one of pure blood those who
hold this title tend to believe that
they are better than everyone else with
the exception of the Weasleys of course
while having magical blood running
through your veins is seen as ideal
there are many amazing wizards and
witches who are half blooded or
muggle-born holding on to a sacred
bloodline isn't easy however especially
since pure blood families are scarce
with this in mind many pure blood
families tend to marry within their
circles which can have disastrous
effects did you know that Molly
Weasley's has some black in her family
tree if so you might have realized that
that makes her cousins with the Malfoy's
in the end the truth about the pure
Bloods is that their lineage is being
recycled due to not having enough to go
around it has often been said that if
wizards did not mate with muggles the
fate of the Wizarding World would have
taken a hit luckily a wizard's talents
can still be passed down on to muggle
bloodline they attend to people's tastes
is that considered a dangerous
profession high school dropouts there's
a dark truth that many of us Harry
Potter fans never considered and this is
that Ron and Harry never actually
graduated from Hogwarts surely we all
knew that Hermione Ron and Harry were
skipping out on their last year at
Hogwarts to save the Wizarding World
this seemed out of character for
Hermione who was devoted to her
education like no one else in the end
though sacrifices had to be made after
the Battle of Hogwarts Hermione decided
to return to school and finish her last
year this makes her a Hogwarts graduate
unlike her life partner and best friend
Harry and Ron did not see the point in
going back to school they felt like they
had already graduated from that period
of their life Rowling confirmed that
these two buddies never received a
diploma however she also stated that
they didn't need one to get the jobs
they wanted in the end it isn't common
for dropouts to work at the Ministry of
Magic
but exceptions can be made for those who
deserve it does it bother you that these
two heroes never went back for their
diploma or do you think that they made
the right choice Dumbledore is death
when Rowling finished writing the last
Harry Potter book she knew that her fans
would come out with wild theories what
she didn't expect however was for one of
them to make
so much sense by now you're all familiar
with the tale of three brothers this
story is mentioned throughout the
deathly hallows plotline if you aren't
though allow us to fill you in a bit
when three brothers managed to cheat
death he granted them each a wish these
wishes gave birth to the Elder Wand the
resurrection stone and the cloak of
invisibility when the brothers departed
death silently waited to claim their
lives however he was unable to claim the
last brother's life because he couldn't
locate him the fan theory behind this
story goes as follows
Voldemort is the first brother the one
who asks for the most powerful wand of
all time Snape is the second brother the
one who desperately wanted to bring his
lover back from the grave Harry is the
last brother the one who wanted to live
a beautiful life free from the fear of
death so where does that leave
Dumbledore that's easy Dumbledore is
actually death himself and he waits for
Harry to die and grieve him like an old
friends does this make any sense to you
we sure hope so because it's Rowling
approved which dark theory was your
favorite let us know in the comments and
that's a wrap don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more great content to
come your way thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]